thanks for having me it was this is my
first invited
in-person talk for two years so i was
extremely excited to get here and take a
plane
um so yeah so um
you know when we consider the role of
data in judgment and decision making
visualization interfaces are often
relevant and visualization's the area i
work in
because visualizations influence how we
interact with and make decisions from
data and predictive systems in a variety
of settings you know from daily life
where we see model predictions related
to things like elections or public
health through visual visual interfaces
as well as visually driven exploratory
analysis where we have tools like
tableau and other
programmatic tools like r that people
are using to make decisions in
organizations or in science and then
finally visualizations in the scientific
literature convey results under
uncertainty
and in these various settings you know
visualization techniques are often
preferred um for interacting with data
because they have this ability to
offload cognition to perception as we
like to say making it easier for us to
identify patterns and relationships
so for example anselm's quartet many of
you potentially have seen before it's a
set of four data sets which would look
identical if we were to summarize these
just using summary stats like the mean
and the variance of x and y if we run a
regression we get the same regression
equation
um and these these four data sets were
were created specifically to show that
you know summary stats are limited and
when we visualize them we immediately
see aspects of distribution that we
would otherwise miss
and so in the last few decades research
on uh interactive visualization or
information visualization has brought in
from addressing only analysis i would
say to consider
you know communication and decision
making from data as well
but when it comes to how we view sort of
the function of visualizations
and visualization systems that we're
building even within research i would
say that pattern finding is still kind
of our common emphasis
so for example if you look at the state
of the art in visualization systems
being published on today our design
ethos seems to be driven by what we
might call behavioral optimizations so
you know ways of making the data easy to
access and to see so that the user can
find patterns
so we see advances like visualization
recommender systems
like voyager that suggests views based
on perceptual or statistical features
uh behavior-driven recommendation where
we're learning from low-level
interaction data to predict what view
someone might want to see next
touch pen-based displays and speech and
natural language based displays all
under this this guise of you know making
it very easy for someone to see the data
whatever modality is useful for them
so all of these forms of optimization
would suggest that you know as designers
of visual visual analysis tools and
visualization systems we just need to
sort of give people access to the data
get uh make the system sort of get out
of their way
implies that we can assume that the user
knows what to do when they see patterns
in the data we just want to sort of
serve it up as quickly and efficiently
as possible
and the notion that visualization is
about exposing patterns may largely be a
carryover from the way that the the
field was sort of born as a discipline
or some of our our biggest influences so
tukey for instance popularized this idea
of exposure as he called it are using
graphics to understand what's in our
data
before we know what to look for he also
talked about how graphs help us see what
we didn't expect
help us sort of check our assumptions
and perhaps this has encouraged what
seems like a pervasive view even today
in hci and visualization that you know
exploratory data analysis is mostly
model-free
and certainly eda is difficult to
sort of
reconcile with applications of
statistical modeling and statistical
testing or what we would call
confirmatory statistics so for instance
it's not clear whether all of the
activities in exploratory analysis like
hypothesis generation
are going to be something that we can
even fit within a confirmatory or a
probabilistic framework so there's hard
questions about like what is eda and how
does it interface with other aspects of
statistics
and perhaps you know these difficult
questions make us fall back on this
belief maybe just simply because it's
simpler of thinking that you know
visualization is about finding patterns
it's about generating hypotheses and
it's less about checking the robustness
of patterns um
but the consequences of uh you know
prioritizing pattern finding over
pattern checking is that our tools have
some big blind spots so to take just one
example of an issue that crops up
consider you know how we build defaults
into visual analysis tools so many
systems for visual data analysis like
tableau will aggregate data by default
to
basically enhance pattern identification
when you have very large data sets but
of course many companies and
organizations and individuals are using
tableau and similar systems um to look
at small data and to make decisions from
small data so a couple years ago we
looked uh or we asked novice analysts to
generate observations
about a population
as they assess statistical graphics
showing them a sample from the
population
and we recorded in addition to their
generalizations about the population
their confidence in these
generalizations
and we varied kind of what data sets we
showed them varying things like sample
size and we either showed them
aggregated data like the default and
tableau or disaggregated data
and what we found was that when people
looked at aggregated data and began to
reason about the population they
reasoned much more dichotomously about
effects so they would talk about how
there was a difference or there was not
a difference
but they would not say much about the
size of that difference at all it was
just does it exist or not
we also saw
that people's confidence and the number
of generalizations they came up with
about the population
tended to not be very affected by
changes in the sample size of the data
they were looking at
so you know we would want people to be
less confident in things that they think
they see when the when the data is
suddenly much smaller but with
aggregated data you know people miss
they miss cues about sample size that
are actually quite important
and so
you know uh these sort of blind spots in
our tools um
in many ways i think um and much of my
work has been about um arguing are sort
of based on a lack of sort of grounding
in theory and in particular in theories
of inference in the way that we're
building visual analysis tools so we
need to help people see patterns but we
also
need to help them understand what
they're seeing and how those patterns
generalize how robust are they so that
they can make good predictions and
decisions
so today i want to first motivate why
i think a lack of theoretical grounding
uh you know causes problems in in
research on visual analysis practice and
visual analysis and i'm going to look at
the area of uncertainty visualization
which i've worked a lot in
in order to do that
and then i'll talk about what kinds of
theories of statistical inference i
think have been helpful for me at least
in structuring how i think about
visualization and the implications for
visual analysis and visualization tools
so one i'm still sort of adjusting to
talking in a mask so if i feel like i'm
breathing heavily and that's that's the
result
um so yeah so back as a phd student i
became interested in this topic of
uncertainty visualization and found
myself wondering you know why is it such
a niche area in visualization because on
some level you know variability and how
variability compares to signal in data
is is sort of affects every decision we
make from it
and so i became interested initially in
the limitations of existing conventional
uh approaches to visualizing uncertainty
or visualizing distribution is is really
all i mean there
and most of these techniques are static
and they use either summary marks things
like error bars or box plots to
present statistical constructs
you know properties of a distribution or
they use visual variables like color
um
you know position height
um in a in a density plot opacity to
show probability
and the problem with most of these
techniques is that when we apply them or
when we apply sort of canonical criteria
for evaluating visualizations
we see some some major issues
with these kind of approaches so summary
marks for instance create what we could
call expressiveness violations so
expressiveness means we want to use
visual encodings that don't lead people
to make inappropriate inferences about
the data so inferences that aren't
supported by the actual data
but people often do this when they look
at error bars based on the way the error
bar looks to them it conveys some false
info
so these include biases like within the
bar bias which refers to how people
tend to think that you know the the
range of values denoted by the bottom
half of the error bar which is on top of
the bar encoding something like a mean
is a more likely range of values than
that than that on the upper half of the
error bar
because it kind of looks that way like
this is somehow more connected to the
data
um there's
other very robust bias called
deterministic construal error which is
where people take a representation that
shows uncertainty and they try to
interpret it as though it's
deterministic so for instance in weather
domain if i want to give you
an uncertainty interval around a
predicted high temperature
even when you try very hard to tell
people that's what they're seeing
there's still this sort of robust
tendency to interpret it as the daily
low and the daily high
and finally
there's you know a lot of issues that
stem simply from the challenges people
have in interpreting some of the
underlying statistical constructs that
we're trying to show with things like
error bars so
um you know there's been multiple
studies at this point showing that
psychologists and grad students have
you know make them a lot of mistakes in
trying to interpret how a 95 confidence
interval relates to the concept of
statistical significance so even people
using these techniques have trouble
getting the interpretation right
and then there's you know other common
interpretations like a 95 confidence
interval is the value in which the true
you know population parameter would fall
95 percent of the time
which you know
seems kind of intuitive but is wrong
because in a frequentist context we
can't talk about a population parameter
having any probability it's just a fixed
value
so the statistics
beneath these things are hard
on the other hand when we look at
probability encodings as a way to encode
uncertainty we run into what we could
call effectiveness issues related to how
well people can read the data back from
the visualization
the biggest problem is that we often
want to use our most effective encodings
things like position to show the data
itself and we tend to be left with less
effective encodings to show probability
um so
you know for instance when we map you
know probability to height in a density
plot we run into issues
where people
are trying to do basically one-sided
probability intervals um and they have
to rely basically on an area judgment to
do it and people are not good at area
judgments um the worst part is that some
of the encodings that kind of look the
most like uncertainty so things like
opacity and blur make people people
think semantics semantically about
uncertainty um but these are some of the
hardest to for people to read data from
so if i asked you you know
what's the probability of
you know value here versus a value here
you probably you know be very bad at
that judgment
and so based on an understanding of
these problems i started to work on the
idea of frequency-based uncertainty
visualization back when i was a phd
student motivated in part by this robust
finding from cognitive psych research
that in some cases re-expressing a
probability as a frequency can help
people better use it in
bayesian reasoning tasks
so rather than saying 30 percent of the
time we can say three out of ten times
so frequency based uncertainty
visualization is trying to apply this
discrete or frequency framing to
visualization
and there's a few techniques that came
out of this the one that's closer to
sort of conventional uh visualization of
uncertainty but frequency framed as a
quantile dot plot this was a
collaboration with matt k
where we wanted to give lay people
represent representation of uncertainty
and bus arrival times initially that
would help them make quick decisions
about when to get to the bus stop given
their tolerance for risk
so with a small number of dots like 20
dots
you know quantile dot plots support
reasoning well or easily about
one-sided probability intervals which is
often what you care about when you're
thinking about when should i get to the
bus stop because people can
rely on what's called subitizing the
ability of the visual system
to sort of immediately recognize small
counts of objects so you don't actually
have to count them um you can just sort
of recognize um usually for things up to
about four or five what it is and so we
found that the bus riders could use
these
and and
basically
make better probability judgments
the other technique i call hypothetical
outcome plots where we're simply taking
random draws from a target distribution
which might be a joint distribution in
multivariate cases and presenting each
draw from the distribution as a frame in
an animation
without changing really the underlying
visual encoding that the visualization
the static visualization would have used
um and the idea here is that we can show
people sort of what uncertainty looks
like and watch they can watch it kind of
play out
so it's the nicest part is that we can
express uncertainty
using this discrete framing in a
visualization that's already pretty
complex in terms of its visual encodings
we don't have to add a new visual
encoding
and we've applied it therefore to cases
where uncertainty would otherwise just
be difficult to visualize so it's hard
to add an error bar to a lot of common
you know visualizations so we've applied
it to cases like i want to
reason about uncertainty in community
membership in a network diagram
or
i want to think about
things like icon arrays and how do i
show people that there's uncertainty in
a rate
spatially interpolated maps all of these
techniques where we don't
we don't really have an uncertainty
visualization approach
but of course in doing this work we've
had to grapple with you know how do you
evaluate these new techniques and i've
kind of skipped over that and talking
about the techniques themselves but it's
really in evaluating these types of
visualizations that i began to sort of
recognize how in many ways
in visualization
us researchers really don't know what
we're what we're looking for designing
for
why do we really want a better
uncertainty visualization
so for example a few years ago i
evaluated about 90 experimental
evaluations of uncertainty
visualizations
looking at what behaviors they hoped to
change
how how they measured success and i
found that the vast majority of
evaluations were about reading the data
from the visualization things like
comparing how accurately people could
extract information like the max or the
average from some display or maybe how
well they could rank random variables in
a visualization
or if they weren't about reading the
data they were about sort of how
satisfied people felt in using the
visualization
and this is problematic in a few ways so
there's no guarantee that just because
someone can read the data from a
visualization when you ask them that
they will actually use it and
incorporate it in a decision under
uncertainty
there's also no guarantee that someone
who feels like the visualization is nice
to use is actually going to benefit from
that
um you know we can think of like the new
york times election needle um from 2016
where you know it was kind of an
effective uncertainty visualization you
couldn't ignore the uncertainty but
people hated it
um and so one thing that's hard to get
at in particular when when looking at
things like accuracy or satisfaction and
evaluation is how people are extracting
information from the visualization and
using it to update their beliefs to make
decisions
and one thing that that we might want to
to think about is really the strategies
people use to make decisions um not just
you know whether they can report
statistics
so one generic yet i think pretty
important type of uncertainty judgment
is how people perceive what's called
effect size so given two distributions
one common measure of effect size is
called the probability of superiority or
a common language effect size which is
the proportion of the time or the
probability that a random draw from one
distribution will be higher than a
random draw from the other so you can
think of it as sort of this this measure
of how effective an intervention is
and of excess is an interesting type of
judgment to look at with uncertainty
visualization because it should inform
many decisions we make
from data it's also the kind of judgment
that you know should be happening all
the time when we look at visualizations
and even when we're looking for patterns
we should be intuitively sort of seeing
differences but wayne how important are
these differences given the variation in
each distribution and so the question i
started asking is you know how well do
different visualizations support effect
size judgments and decisions
and in my initial research on
hypothetical outcome plots we looked at
how different uncertainty visualizations
impact this kind of judgment and i
observed in particular that users of
error bars and violin plots seem to map
the difference in means they saw in a
visualization to an effect size scale or
probability scale so if it was a big
difference between means they'd say this
was a big effect or high probability
of superiority and if it was a small
difference in mean they'd say low
probability
b is greater than a
and of course this is not perfect
because we should be also accounting for
how much variance there is in in each
group not just the distance between the
means
um and so there's this question too what
defines a big or a small difference how
are people sort of relatively judging
the size of the mean distance and
mapping that
so the heuristic kind of implies that
it's somehow relevant to you know some
other distances in the chart
so one possibility is that big and small
um differences between means are judged
relative to the total space in a
visualization so in a 2d chart you know
the total space that's relevant
is uh you know the the total vertical
space um on the y-axis
so
uh
in a recent experiment we tried to to
look at this more closely we asked
people to judge effect size and state
willingness to pay for a treatment given
either 95 confidence intervals or 95
predictive intervals so they got the
corresponding interval information
in text so
people who saw this chart got
information about these intervals and
vice versa
same data set so these are equivalent
we're just showing sampling
distributions versus measurement
distributions
and um
we
we basically found that you know the
people who saw
the the chart with the ci's they saw a
big distance you know and they they were
much more willing to overpay for the
treatment and they said the effect size
was much higher than they did here so
then we tried to look at well could we
rescale
the y-axis to make some of this this
difference go away so what if we showed
95 percent ci's but we scaled the y-axis
to fit the 95 predictive intervals would
this help and it did in fact attenuate
some of the bias we were seeing so not
completely but a bit
so people were somehow sensitive to the
amount of visual difference or distance
between distributions in a chart
relative um you know to this uh these
other cues that are set up you know by
the total distance in a chart
and so the most focused study we've done
on this
wannabus paper at viz last year we
wanted to more directly still test
whether users rely on a distance between
distributions as a proxy for effects and
so we did a mixed design controlled
experiment on mechanical turk here
and the previous study was on mechanical
turk as well i forgot to mention where
we show distributions with multiple
levels of variance on a common axis
scale such that at lower dis
at lower variance the distance between
means was not a good q for effect size
whereas at higher variance
if you were just looking at distance
between means it maps slightly better to
the actual effect size in the data
and so the task we used was modeled
after a fantasy sports game where the
user's job was to judge the improvement
in team performance when adding a new
player this red distribution you see in
the charts
but the new player would cost them some
money
but it would improve their chances of
winning a bigger monetary award
by getting a score over some threshold
that we gave them
and so on each trial we were asking
users basically
to do a couple different judgments
give us the probability of superiority
or this measure of effect size and then
make a decision about whether you're
going to buy the new player or not
and the expected pattern of
effect size underestimation if the
person is using a distance based
heuristic with either high or low
variance can be seen here
um so this is ground truth effect size
and this is perceived effect size and if
you're just looking at sort of distance
between means
for low variance charts you're going to
really be biased so you're going to
really give a lot of responses close to
50 regardless of ground truth it'll be a
little better at high variance because
with the high variance charts um
distance between means is a better proxy
for effect size and so we wanted to
compare
curves that we fit to our experiment
participants to
these curves
um
and you know the the conditions that we
showed people were based on this
hypothesis we initially had that we
should see behavior closer to these
expected patterns where people are using
the mean distance heuristic if we gave
the participants some visualizations
that made the means more salient
so we should see the biggest difference
if we had a summary mark for the mean to
visualizations that otherwise would make
it hard to see the mean things like
hypothetical outcome plots where it's
it's kind of hard to estimate the mean
particularly when there's a lot of
variance in the distributions and so we
assigned each participant to one of
these four conditions
but they did an initial block
either with means or without means and
then vice versa for a second block so
they're making a bunch of judgments seen
means or not means given one of these
these different representations
and so i'll refer to the paper um or
refer you to the paper for the full
modeling details because um there's a
lot of sort of nuanced results here i
don't have time to go over but basically
we model their judgments in probability
of superiority using a type of linear
and log odds model that's commonly used
for perceptual fermenomona
and we're estimating basically the
slopes of the curves that i showed you
on the previous slide to measure the
degree of bias or underestimation
we also looked at decision bias relative
to utility maximizing decision um both
of these were bayesian models but i'm
just going to summarize the high-level
findings that were sort of informative
for me as someone thinking about
uncertainty visualization so first we
found that adding means had a small
effect on probability estimates that was
consistent with people
using a mean distance heuristic more
when they had a mean on the chart
when we modeled the decision bias
relative to optimal strategy we saw kind
of the same thing so when you added
means people were a little more likely
to be biased in a way that we expected
under this heuristic but what was kind
of surprising to us was that these were
small differences so you know we
expected to see a big difference where
if you add means to certain charts like
the hypothetical outcome plots you'd see
a big change in behavior but there was
no real big change in behavior that we
were seeing and so the big question is
you know why didn't adding the mean have
a bigger effect are people not using the
mean distance heuristic even when we
show them means and so things look
similar
or are they using the mean distance
heuristic whether or not we should we
make them mean salient um and it's this
letter answer that explains um you know
what what we thought we saw so we had
also asked people to report the
strategies they were using in making
these judgments and people
by and large reported using some sort of
distance heuristic looking at the visual
space in the chart looking at the
distance between the distributions and
then mapping that somehow to either a
decision or probability judgment
so this was surprising to us um
and kind of sobering to me as someone
you know thinking oh i'm doing research
on uncertainty visualization i'm trying
to come up with these techniques things
like hypothetical outcome plots that'll
really force people to take uncertainty
into account you know it's pretty
sobering to realize that you know these
heuristics are super pervasive and even
when you give someone a visualization
that is basically giving them this
probability pretty directly like through
the animated lines um they ignore that
and they try to estimate the means and
then look at the distance between them
so
it really sort of points to how
you know as researchers one we shouldn't
just blindly trust that people know how
to gauge the reliability of patterns
trends or differences they see in in
charts but also we need to better
understand what people are actually
doing with visualizations um
not just assume that because you know
theoretically some visualization should
be better that is actually going to help
people in the way we think
and i think what's tricky here is like
we designed this experiment you know
pretty carefully
um to get at a heuristic we had the
heuristic in mind we learned a lot by
doing so but in general designing these
types of decision experiments is a hard
process there's a lot of chance for it
to go wrong so you have to reason
carefully about you know what is the
right task what is the right payoff
function um you know what's the data
generating process to create the stimuli
and there's many many chances to sort of
end up with an experiment design that
simply will not be powerful enough to
differentiate you know the behaviors
that you might think are going on
and so i think
you know in recent years what i've spent
more and more time on after learning
these kind of things through uncertainty
visualization research is is this idea
of like what is a good theory of what
people should be doing with
visualizations that will be kind of
generalizable so that we're not trying
to design these one-off decision
experiments always
but we have some theory of like you know
what how people learn from data
and so three years or so ago i began
thinking about how bayesian theory can
be kind of generalized and help us think
about learning from visualization and
analysis
so for example initially my student
former phd student yes so kim and i
started using invasion models of
cognition to look at how well people
seem to update their beliefs given
visualized data so the experimental
paradigm we used involved either first
eliciting or endowing people with prior
beliefs about some parameter
could be something like you know the
proportion of people in some population
that have a disease
um where you know we elicited or gave
them prior beliefs and then we showed
them data like a survey of how many
people in some sample have the disease
and the data sort of represents kind of
the likelihood of different possible
values of that parameter in this case
which is it's a rate
we can compare uh
we can elicit their posterior beliefs
and then compare those to sort of what
we would expect if the user was a
normative kind of bayesian agent who
perfectly updated their beliefs given
the prior and that likelihood function
so it gives us a way to sort of think
about like how much information are
people getting from a visualization
relative to what we might hope a
rational agent would get
so we did a few large um
experiments on mechanical turk
with this sort of paradigm
and we varied parameters we asked people
about we varied the size of the datasets
we varied how they were visualized and
we learned quite a bit that i think i
for me as an uncertainty visualization
researcher was kind of surprising
because i'd never seen any of this come
up in the literature so for example many
of you maybe have heard of belief in the
law of small numbers which basically
says that people over trust uh
information from small samples we found
there was sort of a robust tendency to
over update from small samples it was
kind of small though in comparison to
this much larger bias we saw where
people would tend to under update from
very large samples so you know big data
set gives you a lot of information but
people would not update their beliefs
nearly as much as a bayesian would
with that data
and so um you know we've we can use sort
of a similar paradigm to then try to get
out well why is it that people are sort
of insensitive to data and especially as
data sets get bigger
um you know is it because they distrust
the source of the data and so they're
discounting from that
is it a perceptual thing like
logarithmic
perception affects how we perceive many
quantities is it something perceptual is
it a cognitive bias and so in some
follow-up work we've tried to get at
this
looking at sort of how much these
different factors may come into play
we also
can look within a framework like this
and get a better sense of exactly how
much something like a better uncertainty
visualization might help
so in particular we gave people
different uncertainty visualizations and
then we calculated what we called the
perceived sample size so the sample size
that the bayesian would have needed to
see in order to arrive at that that set
of posterior beliefs given that prior
and we found that with a better
uncertainty visualization you can get
people to perceive the the data set size
with a little less bias so they pers
their perceived sample size is closer to
what it should be
but even good uncertainty visualizations
and this other approach we did of
uncertainty analogies where we basically
told them how much weight the data
sample should get relative to the prior
they did not really get rid of these
biases so there's
this very strong tendency to under
update um and we could kind of like
attenuate it a little um but not get rid
of it
in another recent paper that was led by
alex kale my phd student we used a
different variant of bayesian cognitive
modeling where we did several
experiments where we gave people a data
set along with graphs of several
different possible causal models that
might have generated the data and we had
sort of the typical
you know causal
situation where you have a gene that
causes the disease a treatment that may
or may not affect the disease and some
other unobserved factors and so we
basically wanted to to give people data
sets
and give them possible causal models
that might have generated the data and
we varied how we showed them the data we
gave them everything from like text
contingency tables to you know bar
charts that map to those tables
interactive
or filterable bar charts icon arrays and
interactive icon arrays and we wanted to
see you know how well could they
differentiate which model was
um sort of more consistent with the data
they were seeing and we used a bayesian
cognition approach called causal support
to do this which is basically assigning
posterior probability to some set of
causal models given some data set
and again we learned a lot by using this
kind of normative model so first and
again in sensitivity to sample size
which we were less surprised by this
time but
still very robust in this we also
learned that people were more sensitive
when they were evaluating possible
causal models to
evidence that falsified
some model rather than evidence that
would confirm or be in support of some
model being the true data generating
model that was interesting to us but
most surprising was that visualization
did not help so giving people a text
contingency table worked just as well as
giving people visualizations
which was weird to us again because in i
think in particular you know when we
talk about visual analysis and visual
visualization tools um we often sort of
casually throw around words like oh yeah
people do sort of causal attribution
they look at data they figure out what's
going on
and you know then when we sit some
people down and have them do this again
these were these were sort of lay people
they were not analysts so it would be
interesting to see what happened with an
analyst population but
by and large you know people were very
very bad at this um so so what is going
on do we really know how how good people
are at these very basic tasks
and so this line of work invasion
cognitive modeling is sort of informed
how i think these days about
visualization and its function
and a theory i like recently which i
would hope that tooky
you know would like as well kind of
aligns with his idea about different
phases of eda and kind of what ties
between these initial very exploratory
phases where we're generating hypotheses
and kind of these more probabilistic
phases where we're trying to evaluate
how much support data gives us for
different explanations
um
and so uh the the idea is that you know
a visualization supports what we call a
model check um and this this goes back
to speculation in the stats literature
around 20 years ago about how visual
inference looking at a visualization and
making inferences is kind of related to
statistical testing so in particular
andrew gellman proposed the idea that a
model check could unite exploratory and
confirmatory analysis
which is are as i as i said before hard
to it's hard to sort of reconcile
how these two phases of analysis go
together the idea is that you know a
good graph helps one check their
intuitive statistical model about kind
of how the data were generated
and this idea always seemed quite
powerful to me as someone who thinks a
lot about like how exactly people draw
inferences from visualization because it
generalizes across you know different
phases of analysis so for example you
know say i'm a real estate agent and i
have some housing sale data for my area
and i might construct plots like these
using a tool like tableau
and i'm looking for things like wizard
effect of neighborhood or what's the
effect on this relationship between
different lot configurations um if i
also cross it by neighborhood
or you know what's the
um
you know the relationship between the
square footage of living space and
bedroom space
and as well as sale price like how do
those factors predict sale price
and in any of these you know
visualizations that i might construct to
answer these questions i'm basically
checking for main effects i'm sort of
laying out the data in ways that allow
me to look for certain visual signatures
or certain visual patterns that will
denote to me that there's a main effect
so is there do i perceive a difference
in the in the
location and scale of these
distributions that's sort of looking for
a main effect on location and a main
effect on on variance and so
um if you think about it you know in
particular basic statistical graphics
that we think about um things like
histograms and by various scatter plots
are useful because all we have to do is
look for deviations from symmetry in a
lot of cases and the visual system is
very good at this so we compare
histograms to bell curves or other
standard distributions depending on what
the data look like to us and what they
cue in our mind
you know we're looking for
perceived you know relationships
bivariate relationships and scatter
plots by simply looking you know how
well the data fit a diagonal line maybe
some kind of polynomial that we're
imagining and some of the most effective
plots that we see for formally checking
model fit things like quantile quantum
plots or qq plots or residual plots are
designed in such a way that the
reference model that you're supposed to
be checking is kind of built in to the
design of the graphic so you know for a
residual plot we want to see the
residuals bounce randomly around the
zero line they should roughly form a
horizontal band and again all we'll do
is look for deviation from symmetry
and as we look at the plot you know you
can imagine that we're implicitly sort
of comparing the deviation we see maybe
you know how far off from center the
horizontal line is
and then maybe we're judging you know
how bad is the deviation or how bad is
the model misfit relative to like how
bad it might be so almost like we're
doing sort of you know calculating kind
of an internal p value for like how
important is whatever how unlikely is
what i saw
and we can get more specific and some of
the work i've been doing recently sort
of talks about this more specific
formalization of this where we think
about our examinations of visualizations
as akin to doing what's called a
posterior predictive check in invasion
statistics
we can think of the posterior predictive
distribution from a bayesian model as
kind of like a reasonable data generator
so under that model and that set of
assumptions what should the data look
like and it's a very powerful idea if we
think about you know
people and using graphs who might have
implicit sort of models that they're
maybe trying to imagine like what would
the data look like under this
possibility that they're comparing to
the visualization so
you know for one we can design
experiments given this kind of this idea
or this modeling framework for you know
specific data generating processes and
we can look at how well people do these
these internal model checks but the
other big reason for having kind of a
theoretical sort of um
framework like this um that's sort of
generative
is uh that we can also think about well
how should we design visual analysis
visual analysis tools differently if we
assume that people are sort of
implicitly comparing these kind of
models of how data were generated
so for example you know how can we help
users of visual analysis tools um you
know do this more easily even if they're
not you know trained in thinking in
terms of modeling um you know and
statistics themselves
and there's sort of the lower level
ideas so if we think about you know um
analysis of visualizations and inference
from visualizations as kind of a
bayesian process where people are
checking models some things seem like
pretty obvious so we should default to
presenting the raw data for instance or
we should be presenting uncertainty
whenever someone wants to see you know
statistics like means because in a
bayesian framework people need a sense
of likelihood
and you know you have to see
the uncertainty to get a sense of
likelihood we can also think about
things like supporting representations
of prior um prior uh distributions or
prior beliefs which we might learn from
past data so somebody's analyzing
similar data you know once a month
because they work for some firm and
they're always doing like a monthly
analysis could we learn a prior that
helps them then more easily judge what's
what's unusual about the data they're
looking at or could we elicit priors in
cases where people might have them
so these are a few sort of basic ideas
that immediately come to mind but we can
also go a little bit further
and think about
you know
what a system would look like that that
explicitly um supported model checks in
sort of a bayesian framework like i've
been talking about so in current work
with uh or led by my phd student alex
kale we're developing a tableau-like
system that also explicitly supports and
recommends model checks to users um so
an analyst you know is going to interact
with data similar to how they do in
tableau they're going to
drag fields
to specify you know what kind of charts
they want to see they get visualizations
from the tool
but then there's this model
specification backend
that enables explicit comparison of
models to check against observed data
so for any plot i have the option
of also viewing model predictions that
can help me understand how different
combinations of variables explain or
don't explain what i think i'm seeing in
a graph so i can manually specify models
for instance if i'm comfortable with
that
so we've kind of built in like a little
model bar
into the visual analysis tool you can
imagine something like tableau or power
bi
or i can if i'm not comfortable writing
regressions myself i can accept
recommendations from the tool about what
models might be relevant for me to check
against what i'm seeing
so the core question behind doing this
is kind of like what's the right
alignment or coupling between the models
that people should check and the
visualizations so a visualization in
some ways you could say implies a model
because you have some number
you know say of predictor variables so
here we have day of week we have some
outcome variable here this is forest
fire data so we're looking at the log of
the amount of uh
land that was burned
um and so you know i can look at um
predictions from a model that
incorporates
the variables that are in my chart
specification and try to see like do i
see any discrepancies if i'm predicting
log area burned by day of week you know
how good are my predictions at
um
sort of replicating the the location and
the the scale of each of these
distributions i see
in other cases you know
showing someone predictions from a model
based on the chart specification they're
looking at might help them avoid like
obvious failures of reasoning so here
imagine i'm looking at some
self-tracking study data i might care
how hours of sleep per night seems to
relate to fitness level so i have hours
of sleep and fitness level and then i'm
dividing it by the reported sex of the
person using the tracker and whether
they've used a sleep tracker before
and i might you know working in
something like tableau
you know want to see a trend line
because it's sort of you know i'm really
interested in how these relationships
between fitness level and hours of sleep
change
under these two um
you know nominal covariates that i'm
looking at and maybe i think i see oh
there's maybe some interaction effect
where for males who have previously used
trackers
um you know there's a slightly more
positive trend um as fitness level goes
up they sleep more
but you can imagine that if i could see
predictions from a model
in this case fit to the structure of my
graph so i'm looking basically for main
effects of sex previous use of sleep
tracker and fitness level on hours of
sleep
and i'm including all interactions this
could help the user realize that like oh
yeah even though i think i see like a
slight interaction it's totally just
noise you know based on the low sample
size of my data
and so there's you know
both this opportunity to help people
reason about variables that explain
their data but also recognize when
things are wrong or when they're when
they're drawing conclusions that aren't
supported
and a design hypothesis we have is also
that in many cases it might be useful to
toggle between models implied by a view
that someone's looking at
and models that are sort of adjacent um
to the to the the model implied by the
view so here you know i'm seeing um
what happens when i add month to predict
log area so if i don't have month i see
one thing
if i add month i can suddenly see that i
explain the data a bit better this
example is actually cheating a little
because i also got rid of
some zero um zero values but you can
kind of get the idea it's sort of
helping me reason about which which
factors
in my chart actually matter which is
what visual analysis is about but visual
analysis is a little more approximate
of course there's plenty of challenges
in trying to do something like this so
first feasibility
realistically you know complexity has to
be constrained we probably need
analytical solutions in many cases to
fit the models
also the types of users who might
benefit from this are probably not the
people who are comfortable you know
running regressions in r um and so we
have to think about you know if we're
trying to walk people through sort of
checking model fit what kind of
scaffolding or visual guidance do we
have to give them to to allow them to do
that
how do we let them customize things
which as they get comfortable with
modeling they might want to do
but also perhaps most importantly you
know how do we avoid overwhelming people
so if we're going for people who aren't
expert statisticians already who could
benefit from a little more rigorous sort
of model checking as they do visual
analysis you know how do we not um
not just make them want to give up
because it seems hard and i think that's
a and a particularly hard question and
um you know one that you know really
motivates why we're building this system
i think it's hard to answer whether
something like this could work well
without actually trying it um and i'm
fully open to the idea that actually
maybe
maybe people when they do visual
analysis you know they can do okay
without this explicit support you know
maybe we're building these tools and
we're we're sort of um
you know helping them find patterns and
maybe that's okay but i think we really
sort of need theory to sort of ground
actual evaluations of this kind of
intuition we might have and so
so yeah so i'm i could see it going
either way and i'm just sort of curious
what we learn
i have just one or two minutes are we
good on time okay
so anyway the main argument you know i
wanted to make today is for more theory
and visualization in hci more broadly
really so i've spent a while on how
normative theories of statistical
inference can be applied to
designing visualization tools but i also
see a big gap in visualization research
when it comes to kind of formalizing the
problems that we study and the
approaches we take more broadly so
there's a question you know is all this
trouble we go through as researchers
trying to find like the best
visualization or best sediment coatings
or best interaction really worth it
um and i think really a big open
question is what sort of inference
problems do we think we're addressing
with visualization or do we want to be
addressing so in stats there's something
that's sort of casually called the
anthropic principle which says that you
know there's only certain problems where
statistical modeling can help us so if
the signal is huge relative to the noise
you don't need statistical monitoring
and i would assume that we would all
agree that visualization should suffice
here if the signal is huge relative to
noise and then on the other hand you
know
if the the noise is so huge compared to
the signal that we're sort of hopeless
even with statistical modeling
presumably we're hopeless with
visualization as well
um but then there's this middle region
so do we think that this is where most
of the the applications where
visualization can help um
lie and if so
you know how do we get away without
supporting
um you know inference and uh helping
people check the reliability of their
decisions are people convincing
themselves that things don't exist or do
we think that people are are sort of
following up every visual analysis they
do with formal statistical modeling is
that the way we approach the design of
our tools like we don't have to worry
about the other stuff
um
you know i think there's also this
possibility that you know for some types
of problems um visual analysis is robust
enough on its own but how do we actually
state what those problems are i think if
you asked anyone in the field you know
to argue for when visualization alone is
sufficient
they would not be able to tell you that
and so sort of final um project i'll
just briefly share and then then i'll
wrap up is that i've started to work
kind of more with theory colleagues
which i find quite exciting um as an hci
or visualization person we tend to be
very empirical and not theoretical and
so there's a few projects that have been
coming out of this that i think are cool
um we did some work thinking about
visualization in strategic settings
where we sort of defined what we call
the visualization equilibrium so what is
the display that induces the behavior
that is actually predicted by the
display
but in a current project we're designing
a framework to try to answer questions
to help us predict sort of the potential
benefit that a more expressive
visualization might have across a
broader range of data conditions than we
can usually study in experiments or a
broader set of decision tests so for
example what can we say about the stakes
involved when we decide to aggregate
data by default in some tool
and we're doing this basically by
relying on comparisons to how much a
rational agent could benefit from more
information
about distributions
and then we can use that that difference
for the rational agent using basically
optimal scoring rules um to to bound how
well any behavioral agent could could do
with the the the two visualizations
one's more expressive and less we can
plug in different assumptions about the
data generating process or even
different decision tasks and then and
then reason more formally about the
impacts on visualization judgment so i'm
excited about this work it's still very
early
but really because i do see this big gap
in how we think about visualization and
what problems it solves um and things
like aggregation which are so
fundamental to visualization practice so
i'll stop there i have to of course
thank all my collaborators my phd
students and ras
and thanks for listening and inviting me
so happy to take any questions
um thank you for this i was wondering in
your work how do you separate for
example
people's discomfort with uncertainty as
a whole and the tendency towards like
making sense of data to the methods that
you're
evaluating
so i think i mean
people's discomfort and tendency to
ignore uncertainty is kind of um
what a lot of my work has sort of looked
at i think because it's sort of
inevitable when you're studying any sort
of like displays to help people with
reasoning under uncertainty i mean i
think the heuristics is one example um
like people will ignore uncertainty um
it's easier to do so um you know there's
even studies in behavioral econ that
show that in many cases it's optimal to
do so like to ignore it to some for
certain types of tasks and so
you know i think my my goal there is
just um
you know how do we use like empirical
experiments to try to really hone in on
exactly how they're ignoring it um so
some of the studies i was showing i
would say like that's the way we're
engaging with it is by trying to figure
out um you know
in particular like when people are
ignoring uncertainty information they're
usually substituting something else in
so like how do we figure out what
they're substituting in so then we can
you know reason about how bad it is so
some of the visual distance stuff i
would say it's like that but it is hard
to design
it's hard to design studies to get at
these things and in particular often
multiple heuristics
that might seem meaningfully different
to us will be very hard to statistically
differentiate through experiments and so
that's partially i mean kind of the
motivation for theory as well is that
um you know sometimes like empirical
data alone can't answer the questions
but i don't know if that was there
anything more specific
um
i was wondering um more specifically
like on the for example the new york
times needle example right it's
for someone who actually genuinely cares
about trying to understand it it is
useful
but then if someone
like
non-experts especially would just get
turned off and not want to use this yeah
at all
so like
no i think that's a huge problem yeah
yeah i think that's why i mean that's
why my my questions right now are
getting more towards like how robust are
these heuristics people use because i
think
um you know there is an aversion to
uncertainty in general like this is what
the behavioral economists spend all
their time doing you know judgment
decision making people think about this
um
and i think yeah to unders to develop
uncertainty visualizations for sure we
need to be thinking kind of even outside
the bounds of any particular study but
like what happens if in the real world
people never even use this thing to
begin with um so yeah i think that's
i mean i think we need to broaden our
scope as researchers to to think about
like the other alternatives people have
for interacting with that type of data
in general um and i haven't seen anyone
do that well
um yeah including myself so
it's a good point
um but yeah i think that's that's what
i'm we're hopefully working towards in
some ways
so the first question uh about uh some
of your earlier work on uncertainty
visualization through animation and i'm
wondering you know basically
how
you know how you approach this
when there are very large data sets
where it would take a long time to view
the oh yeah
so we're not we're not showing
um yeah so typically i mean you could
just do bootstrap resampling but you
don't the idea is you don't have to see
all of them like what you would want and
we've we've done a little of this only
but like
you want to sort of like um stack the
set of draws so that even in a small
number people are getting a
representative depiction of the
distribution
and there's ways to do that we haven't
actually evaluated any of it but but
yeah i think that's um
that's a that's a big question there's
also hybrid approaches and it's
interesting there because then you do
run into this trade-off where if you
give people animation and
a static summary in the background which
is actually what the new york times
needle was doing it had both the needle
and
and a sort of color visualization in the
back you always then then you run the
risk of them falling back on the static
stuff um
so yeah i think there's a lot of
interesting questions still there in
particular with animation of uncertainty
that are left to be looked at in studies
um
but yeah
yeah i think someone should do it
um well i have another question too and
so i think you know this role of
cognitive biases that people have and
the heuristics that people are using in
their decision making processes um and i
thought yeah the work that you did kind
of uncovered some really interesting
ones and of course there's kind of like
you know again thinking about how you
know decision science and other things
have been applied to hci and
individualization and
to some extent as well uh you know
there's the sense of like common you
know cognitive biases yeah i hate that
kind of stuff on it
like we have to define the biases pretty
specifically i think if we're going to
talk about them and sometimes that gets
skipped
yeah
kind of my question is yeah basically oh
you have some heuristic set of
heuristics that people have and then you
know your work is really looked at you
know very specific strategies
and i guess how do we bridge this gap or
where
basically if we have to run you know
as you mentioned design these studies
very challenging do we need to you know
basically redo everything that
behavioral economists have done
so i think we need to be more careful
when we look at what they're doing i
think i mean the cognitive biases stuff
going on in visualization does often
annoy me because i think they're drawing
from psychology and the definition of
biases were never well defined to begin
with and so
um yeah so things like risk aversion
even like
you can frame it in various ways and it
someone seems both risk seeking and risk
you know averse in the same setting and
so i think my biggest issue is is that
but
i mean i think in general
um like i've learned a ton from
behavioral economics um they will try to
come up with formal models of some of
these things and in particular
um also in mathematical psych where some
of this stuff about like people are
reasoning in terms of samples so not
really reasoning in terms of full
distributions but some of these
heuristics are more like i'm taking a
few samples
people have looked at like
how that can be optimal in various
settings and so i think as cognitive
biases comes into hci and vis we need to
be careful to not just assume this very
negative high level framing
but also think about like
what can we say about when this is a
when this is bad and when this is good
um and that's like i kind of got it in
the talk i think i've moved moving
towards a more theoretical lens at least
in some of my research just because it
is so hard to differentiate these things
um
uh
unless we have some theoretical way of
reasoning as well as the empirical so
i don't know if that answered your
question but i think so yeah okay cool
so on the point of bad definitions for
bias yeah um i was curious how much
you've seen in your work
um
like what biases from the participants
on mechanical turret
do you think may limit some of the yeah
i think
i mean there i think people are even
more likely to satisfy so i've kind of
moved away from doing turk experiments
like sometimes my students still do them
but i
um
i feel like i learn more now from
smaller studies on analysts but it's
also because my my questions have
changed a bit but i think i mean a lot
of the the traditional sort of conneman
and tversky bias stuff
you know they did try to show that a lot
of these things affect experts just as
much as um
lay people um i haven't done as much
work as i'd like in trying to like take
what we find about some of this stuff
with like causal inference and what
people are sensitive to and then apply
it see if it still applies to to
analysts um
but yeah i mean i think in general i
don't know that turkers are different
from other people i think they're just
they're even more likely to satisfy
because they're they're trying to do as
many tasks as they can and
so yeah there's
i think with all of these different
populations you run into some trade-offs
and just trying to
um
yeah ultimately there's a lot of work we
need to do i think to
to be able to compare better like what
affects who most but things like the
non-belief in the law of large numbers
which um some of the behavioral
economists have just recently started to
talk about um i think those kind of
things are
i mean they're framed at a level that
they're they're really baked into like
human perception
so i don't think
i think for a lot of the core bias stuff
the stuff that's well defined
they're they're trying to say things
about people in general and not just
certain pools but yeah it's always a
question and it always needs to be
followed up on to be sure
okay then there aren't any further
questions that i think will thank you
for having me